>>Interviewer: Good afternoon and welcome
to YouTube Headquarters in San Bruno, California,
if you're joining us from somewhere on the
internet.
Our guest today at YouTube is an actor who
has appeared in some of the comedies that
defined the last decade.
I'm talking about movies like 40-Year-Old
Virgin and Superbad, Forgetting Sarah Marshall,
Get Him to the Greek, Funny People and more,
but he's here today to share with us some
of his experiences working in a dramatic role
on a movie that opens this weekend.
The movie is Moneyball.
Please welcome me or please join me in welcoming
to YouTube, Jonah Hill.
[applause]
>>Jonah Hill: Hello.
>>Interviewer: How're you doing?
How're you doing?
>>Jonah Hill: I'm well.
How are you?
>>Interviewer: Good, good.
>>Jonah Hill: Thanks for joining internet
if you're watching this.
Haven't seen you in awhile.
I hope your hair still looks as good as last
time I saw it, internet, and why'd you break
up with me?
That wasn't nice.
OK.
How are you guys doing?
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
So Jonah, I, I could explain what, what Moneyball
is as a movie, but I'm sure people would rather
hear you tell 'em about it.
>>Jonah Hill: Moneyball is a drama about baseball,
but, you know, it's about the 2002 Oakland
A's and Billy Beane and my character, Peter
Brand, using this technique called sabermetrics
or moneyball as they call it.
And they use this technique of a different
way of finding value in players to, to build
a team with very little money that ends up
winning 20 straight games in a row, which
breaks a lot of records.
Now on paper this sounds like the most boring
movie ever made.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: About, a movie about baseball
statistics.
But Aaron Sorkin, who wrote The Social Network,
and Steve Zaillian, who wrote Schindler's
List, wrote, wrote this movie.
And Aaron Sorkin, and I'm paraphrasing here,
said about it, just as how The Social Network
on paper sounds very boring, you know a movie
about someone inventing a website, maybe not
to the people in this room, [chuckles] [audience
laughs] but to me that sounded very boring.
And, and, and you know you watch that film
and it's riveting and really groundbreaking
and cool and a great drama, and it's the same
thing about Moneyball because the filmmakers
really use baseball as a really beautiful
aesthetic backdrop to tell a really moving
story about underdogs and being undervalued.
And that's the story I connected to and also
it stars Brad Pitt and myself and Philip Seymour
Hoffman, so the three most handsome guys in
the world, obviously they, they found us all
and paired us together finally.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And for me it's exciting because
it's you know you're used to seeing me in
comedies and this is, you know I love comedy
movies and dramatic movies, and for me it's
a really big opportunity to show you guys
what I could do in a dramatic role and I hope
you like it, that'd be nice, yeah, sure.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Now it's not as if you only
done kind of one particular style of comedy
over the years, I mean, The Invention of Lying
had a very kind of specific tone to it.
And then even Funny People was a very kind
of naturalistic movie, but still this is a
big step up for you, kind of being head to
head with Brad Pitt?
>>Jonah Hill: Well, I made um, I made a movie
last year called Cyrus, which was a smaller
movie that not a lot of people saw.
And it was myself and John C. Reilly and Marisa
Tomei, and that was kind of good, like it
was a good bridge way in between some of the
comedies I made and, and, and dramatic work
because it was funny and it was a drama, it
had both things in it.
And yeah I mean the thing about the comedies
I've done is to me at the time when, when
I had met Judd Apatow and all these guys you
know like and we all started working together,
it did feel very punk rock and different than
what was going on in comedy.
It felt like a different thing that was happening
and we all kind of have the same energy and,
and, and take on what we wanted to do, led
by Judd obviously.
And you know but now it's years later and
those movies have been copied now to death
and you know in my mind I'm always like, what's
next, how do I evolve and how do you evolve
and then you watch the way that Judd is evolving
as a filmmaker and Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberger
evolving as filmmakers, and now my evolution
involves doing movies like Cyrus and Moneyball
and that's stuff I'm really psyched about,
you know, so hopefully I could get to do both
of those things, the comedy and drama.
>>Interviewer: Now, I've, I've heard some
actors say that it's very intimidating to
work opposite someone like Robert De Niro
because it's Robert De Niro and obviously
Brad Pitt is just so damn handsome.
Do you have to just like stay around for 20
minutes to see if it goes away?
Or how does that work?
>>Jonah Hill: No, you know, honestly, like
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: To what?
>>Interviewer: To just, you know, get past
the initial shock?
>>Jonah Hill: This guy.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Calm down.
>>Interviewer: I have more questions like
this, so.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, yeah.
It's the accent mixed with the tattoos mixed
with the stare mixed with the smile, it's,
it's.
>>Interviewer: We'll be fine.
>>Jonah Hill: Alright.
If anything happens to me, um, I'm in northern
California, in a really weird professor auditorium?
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: I don't know where I am.
But, no, I mean you know obviously I was intimidated
when I got this part because it was myself,
you know I'm the second lead in this movie
with Brad Pitt and Philip Seymour Hoffman's
in the movie and you know Bennett Miller's
directing it who directed Capote, and Aaron
Sorkin wrote Social Network, and Steve Zaillian,
who wrote Schindler's List, and it just is
this really surreal dream-like experience
from day one and so you know the first day
of rehearsals I was really nervous, but I
was like, I can either be really freaked out
or I can kick my nerves to the curb for a
second and try and deliver for these people
who took a chance on giving me an opportunity
to do something truly different, so.
I just wanted to come through for them and
if I was sitting around being nervous about
how talented everyone was, I probably would
of just thought about that as opposed to doing
a good job.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
Now obviously Moneyball really is a, it's
a number of things.
It's a human interest story, it's the story
of Billy Beane, but I don't want to underplay
the role of statistics, obviously we probably
have some you know programmers and engineers.
>>Jonah Hill: Well you guys are nerds, so
it's like
>>Interviewer: Yes, exactly.
>>Jonah Hill: really exciting for you.
>>Interviewer: There are some people here
I'm sure
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Wrong crowd, wrong room, wrong
room.
The internet liked that more than this room.
>>Interviewer: They don't like being called
nerds.
>>Jonah Hill: I'm leaving, no.
>>Interviewer: But I mean how did you deal
with, did you method act your way through
the, the statistical stuff?
>>Jonah Hill: No, well, honestly, I, you know,
I realized I had never played a character
with a skill before, of any kind.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And now the character I was
playing had to be a brilliant statistician
and mathematician, so I had a statistics tutor
and a mathematics tutor and I think that was
probably the hardest job on Moneyball was
teaching me how to count past 10 probably,
because I'm very poor at math and science,
I was always really good at history and English
and acting and stuff like that in school.
>>Interviewer: Now I did read somewhere that
apparently you were kind of suggest, it was
suggested that you should deal with statistics
the same way that you, you kind of talk about
other actors in Hollywood and their strengths
and weaknesses, so.
>>Jonah Hill: Or filmmakers or.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, movies themselves.
>>Interviewer: So I was kind of wondering,
could you maybe give us an example and maybe
give us like two of Seth Rogen's strengths
and one weakness.
>>Jonah Hill: [laughing] I'm not gonna do
that.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: He'll never know.
>>Jonah Hill: Why would I want to?
Next question.
>>Interviewer: Well, what's his strength?
What is a strength that you gained from working
with him?
>>Jonah Hill: Ask him.
I don't know.
What the hell.
>>Interviewer: Alright.
I'll, I'll ask him.
>>Jonah Hill: I flew down to northern California.
Don't ask me about Seth.
He's great.
He's getting married in a couple of weeks,
I'm gonna go to his wedding.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
OK now, Brad is obviously playing very much
the character of Billy Beane, I mean he, there's
a lot of Billy in the book, it's a really
interesting read.
You're playing maybe more of a composite character
and maybe a bigger character that
>>Jonah Hill: Do you work for YouTube?
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Jonah Hill: I thought this was for people
who were on YouTube to ask questions.
>>Interviewer: Well I, we're gonna get to
that.
>>Jonah Hill: [laughing] I wanna hear your
guys' questions, right?
We should hear the people's questions.
>>Interviewer: Alright.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: I thought we were gonna do
some Moneyball questions.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, we can do it, keep going.
But I wanna hear the, I wanna hear the kids
that are on the computer, that's exciting
to me.
Right?
Yeah.
>>Interviewer: OK.
Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: OK, cool.
>>Interviewer: Shall we skip to the questions
that we got from the internet?
>>Jonah Hill: No, no, keep going.
>>Interviewer: Well, I was just kind of interested
in
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: obviously Billy, as I say Billy
is a real character, you're playing more of
a composite character maybe and it's a bigger
part perhaps than it is in the book.
Because in the book you know the character
of the statistician isn't drawn out as much
and I maybe thought that would have been an
interesting opportunity to have that a little
bit grounded in reality, but then you get
Aaron Sorkin writing out the role?
>>Jonah Hill: Well I think, you know, my character
in this movie is a guy who would blend into
a wall, right?
So he's never had a light shined on him before.
He's never had someone empower him in any
way.
He's someone who is doing the busy work on
a computer, no offense, [audience chuckles]
and you don't usually see that person's story
is what I'm saying so for me I found it really
unique to get to play a character where you're
getting to play someone who you're, you're
hearing their story who you don't usually
get to see.
And a guy like Billy, like Brad Pitt's character,
is the guy's character who you always see
in a movie, the main protagonist, but the
cool thing is Brad's character was overvalued.
He was told he was gonna be this big sports
star because he was handsome and he was good
at baseball and he turned down going to Stanford
and he turned down getting an education and
he fizzled out and he didn't become this big
sports star.
And my character is undervalued.
He's taken at face value, taken as a guy who
can just do busy work on a computer, but he
has these really brilliant radical ideas and
Billy's the first person, Brad's character,
Billy, is the first person who sees him and
goes, you're, you're, you're something special,
you have something special to offer.
And it's really cool to see that guy's story.
So that's what I found really interesting.
And it's kind of like seeing a baby use his
legs for the first time, you know, because
he's never been empowered before, so he's
metaphorically wobbling around, you know,
trying to learn how to walk, or trying to
learn how to deal with some sort of power,
and that's exciting.
Yeah.
>>Interviewer: And obviously a lot of this
was filmed at the Coliseum in Oakland.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: And again, that's a little
bit of a character in the book.
You read about the video room and just the
atmosphere, it's certainly not the most palatial
stadium in sports.
>>Jonah Hill: Right.
>>Interviewer: Did that help to kind of soak
up that atmosphere?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
I mean honestly, when we shot there, I mean
there's no more really place you could actually
go than where you're shooting is where it
took place.
And then when you walk out on the field, it's
just the coolest thing ever, because it's
empty and then you know you can run around
the bases and throw the ball around and stuff
and then when we shot a lot of the games that
are really factual about what actually took
place, there were real A's fans in the stadium,
some of whom were at those actual games and
that was really cool, you know, that was really
exciting.
>>Interviewer: So if you were to kind of apply
the theories of Moneyball to the kind of movie
roles that you take and you know Moneyball
being kind of looking for things that are
maybe undervalued or people don't put enough
emphasis on and really kind of leveraging
them, is, is that something that you look
for in roles?
Or you like name big on the poster and a lot
of lines?
>>Jonah Hill: I just look for name biggest
on the poster.
Most amount of free stuff I can get.
No, I've, that's silly, I mean the only thing
I care about, you know, the only thing I care
about is when I'm older and I have grandkids
and I've spent my life doing this, if I'm
lucky to keep getting to spend my life doing
this, that I'll have a few DVDs or whatever
that will be then, it'll be like watched on
your palm or something, I have a few movie
cartridges I can implant into my grandchildren's
brain space.
And say you know this is what I spent my life
doing and I'm really proud of these few things.
And that's, that's all how I look at it because
if you're gonna go away for a few months and
you're gonna go dedicate your life to something,
I mean you guys know, you, everyone in this
room is someone clearly really special and
smart or you wouldn't be working here.
And you could be doing anything with that
intelligence, but it has to be something you're
incredibly passionate about if you're gonna
dedicate not sleeping and working really hard
at it and we're all lucky enough to get to
work on stuff we really care about, if we're
lucky, but the only thing that could be the
impetus of that is thinking it could become
something really special.
>>Interviewer: So obviously you know comedy,
some of the films you've been on, could be
described as about ensemble casts
>>Jonah Hill: Right.
>>Interviewer: a bit of a team sport kind
of thing.
How different is working with Judd to the
kind of the Billy Beane character, I presume
Judd's not throwing chairs around to get you
to, to work.
>>Jonah Hill: Uh, well, um, no I mean Judd
has been, you know, there have been four really
major Billy Beane figures in my life, people
that shined a light on me and gave me the
opportunity to get where I'm at now, which
is YouTube.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: I feel like I've worked my way
backwards from movies to YouTube.
Aren't you supposed to start at YouTube and
then get a movie deal or something when you
make a video of yourself like getting hit
in the nuts with the Frisbee or something,
right?
But no, Dustin Hoffman was the first person
who encouraged me to become an actor and got
me my first audition in what ended up being
my first movie, which is I Heart Huckabees,
and then after that I met Judd, who, you know,
gave me countless opportunities in things
you know to show what I had to offer.
And the next person would be the Duplass brothers,
who gave me Cyrus, which is a movie that I
was able to show a little bit more of a different
side and then finally Brad Pitt and Bennett
Miller, who made Moneyball to give me this
big opportunity and then fifth would be YouTube,
who gave me the opportunity to be here, which
is really cool.
Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
[whoops from the audience]
>>Jonah Hill: I'm here.
I'm at YouTube.
I'm in, while you guys are watching YouTube,
I'm in YouTube, in
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: It's just like a giant tube
filled with, like, kids after the dentist
that like have had too much Vicodin or whatever
and
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: like, you know women stomping
on grapes and falling down and screaming.
[clapping and laughter]
>>Interviewer: So.
>>Jonah Hill: It's a, it's a weird place.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: It's just this giant tube with
weird internet characters.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
So, um
>>Jonah Hill: Excellent.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
So again to get a, to beat this baseball metaphor
to death,
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: as I plan to.
I mean one of the things about Moneyball is
it's inherently a kind of conservative strategy
to, of playing baseball, it's you know take
the walk, don't try and steal the base, get
on base.
It's the opposite of kind of improvisation
and obviously anybody who's seen the DVD extras
and a lot of Judd's movies will know that
you know you've worked in a lot of films where
there's a lot of improvisation.
Is that something that you kind of now look
for as an actor, or?
>>Jonah Hill: No, I just, like I said, you
know, I just I wanna make good movies, whether
they're dramas or comedies, whether they're
improvised or scripted, it, it, it, the process
is not what you're looking for, what, what
will be the finished result being something
that you care about.
I don't want to tread over the same answer
again,
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: which I feel like that kind
of is, but, is, yeah, you just gotta be really
proud of what you're working on or there's
no point in doing it.
So you can't say like, oh, I'm gonna do this
movie because I think it's gonna make a lot
of money, or I wanna do this movie 'cause
it'll get me this or I'm gonna do this because
I'm gonna improvise a lot, like that's all,
you know, no matter how joyous the spirit
of what you're doing is or how annoying it
was to make it or how hard it was to make
or how fun it was to make it, those will always
shift, but if, your goal has to be the product
being good.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: You know?
If you start doing movies for reasons like
oh, they're gonna be a lot of fun, the work
might suffer
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: and the product might suffer.
>>Interviewer: So Philip Seymour Hoffman,
a lot of people would say, an actor's actor?
What did you kind of experience specifically
with him?
>>Jonah Hill: I think, I you know, I was most
intimidated to work with him out of everyone
involved in the movie, because he, you know,
I don't know, because, because he does come
off as this really intense dude from his movies
and, and he's such a gifted actor and I didn't
know what his process would be like at all.
And he was fantastic.
I mean, super fun and funny, but when he's
working, he's very, very, you know, involved
in what he's doing, it's not like joke around
with him before you do a dramatic scene or
something like that, it's pretty intense and
so and the interesting thing is his character
doesn't like my character in the movie and
he doesn't like Brad Pitt's character in the
movie, so we would do these scenes and I would
look at the call sheet and see that Phil was
there that day and I would go, God, this sucks,
because you knew you were gonna get yelled
at all day and he's such a good actor that
it feels like he's really mad at you all the
time, so I'd have to be like, you're not mad
at me or anything, right?
And he's like, no I'm just acting, you know?
So sometimes you felt like as if he was really
upset with you, because he's such a good actor.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
So just to go back a little bit to Superbad,
which obviously had a lot of people kind of
really, you broke through with that.
When you were working on it, was it obvious
at the time that this was you know something
special?
>>Jonah Hill: I think that it was the most
fun movie I've ever made, I'd say.
That and Forgetting Sarah Marshall 'cause
I worked like two days and I was in Hawaii
for like a month.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: But Superbad was the most, it
was like my college experience, because I
wasn't, I had dropped out of school, Michael
Cera was doing that instead of going to college,
and Seth and Evan didn't go, or Evan went
to a little college, but there was just, from
the crew to the cast everyone it was all people
we hung out with in real life.
It was, it was the youngest energy I've ever
felt on a set because everyone was, you know,
like 18 to 25 years old, including the crew
and everyone, you know, except for Judd and
Greg Mottola.
Greg the director and Judd the producer.
And we would, you know, have big parties after
work or on the weekends.
We really all loved each other, so it was
an incredibly, as fun as the movie looks to
make, it actually, sometimes, they look really
fun to make and they're not as fun as that
to make, that one looked really fun to make
and was insanely fun to make.
>>Interviewer: And you were kind of playing
a character that Seth Rogen wrote more or
less himself as a younger person, could you
say
>>Jonah Hill: I think you want to date Seth
Rogen, I'm pretty sure.
>>Interviewer: He's a handsome man.
>>Jonah Hill: He's getting married, but I
think I can.
You seem to be very fascinated by him.
>>Interviewer: I only have four more Seth
questions, we'll get through them quickly.
>>Jonah Hill: I think you should interview
him, man.
>>Interviewer: If he's watching, Seth, if
you're out there, I'm married, but I'll see
what I can do.
I was just really gonna ask, I mean could
you see a point where you were kind of writing
a script based around your own earlier life,
you know would that be an interesting thing
to do?
>>Jonah Hill: I don't know.
I don't know if I ever would.
I've written one script that's autobiographical
that has not been produced into a film and
to me, you know, Superbad was Seth and Evan's
high school experiences and then when Michael
and I came on and then obviously Judd who
worked on it and people, everyone who worked
on it contributed their experiences in what
they felt, you know.
And for me, that, you know, 21 Jump Street
is a movie that I was one of the writers on
and that to me is riffing on making Superbad.
That whole movie to me because I'm playing
a 25-year-old who goes back to high school
in 21 Jump Street as a cop.
But in, when I was making Superbad I was a
20-something-year-old pretending, going back
to high school again, so I got to use a lot
of the experiences that I did to pretend to
be a high school student while making Superbad
in 21 Jump Street as a 25-year-old pretending
to be a high school student again.
Like for example, in Superbad I moved back
in with my parents into my childhood room
while we made the movie because I wanted to
feel like I felt like I was in high school.
And when in 21 Jump Street when our characters
go back to high school, we move in with my
parents again, and so all the funny things,
like your being in your 20s and having your
mom go, what are you doing tonight?
You go, mom, shut up, like, you know, like
you're past that but you have to go back to
that.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: And so 21 Jump Street has a
lot of stuff like that from, from that's riffing
on when I was making Superbad.
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
Now speaking as a parent, I always say to
people that you have to be very careful when
you bring a kid's movie into the house, 'cause
you're gonna end up watching it a lot.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: And from that perspective,
I kind of have to say like How to Train Your
Dragon was, to beat the baseball metaphor
to death, a home run, in every respect.
What was it like to be a part of something
like that?
>>Jonah Hill: Well, thanks.
I mean, that, I will be totally honest with
you guys.
I did not know if that was gonna be a good
movie or not.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: When you do those animated movies,
you're in a booth, they don't show you anything
really and you're just kind of like screaming
and stuff and saying stuff and then you, I
saw it and I was like this is a beautiful
movie, it really is like a beautiful movie
and I was totally surprised.
I had no idea it would be as good as it was
and those directors, they're really beautiful
people and smart, articulate and aesthetically
gifted people and when I watched that movie
I was very surprised at how good and moving
it was.
>>Interviewer: Yeah, I mean it has plot and
action and it's very watchable.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
And dragons are cool.
>>Interviewer: And dragons.
And there's a sequel?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
Another one that I'm just rollin' the dice
on, I just hope it, again.
I mean it's the same guy so, so I think it'll
be great, you know.
But, but, yeah, I, I mean you're just literally
in a booth, there's like no one else around
and they give you some lines and it's like,
watch out for that dragon.
And you're like this could be terrible, I
have no idea, I have no idea what this is
gonna be like, you know?
And then it turned out to be something I'm
really proud of, you know?
>>Interviewer: And you have been in other
animation stuff.
You were, I guess.
in Horton Sees a Hears a Who!?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: You were in Megamind.
>>Interviewer: And you have your own animated
series coming up on Fox?
>>Jonah Hill: Yes.
>>Interviewer: World domination?
Is this the plan?
>>Jonah Hill: I, I don't know, I don't know,
just YouTube domination.
I just want.
Do you guys have a bed here?
I wanna live in this tube forever with you
guys.
>>Interviewer: We have some comfortable couches.
>>Jonah Hill: OK Cool.
You had great hummus.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: I had some hummus.
Have you guys tried the hummus here at YouTube?
It's fantastic.
Great hummus.
Yeah, I created an animated show called Allen
Gregory, with my two friends Jarrad Paul and
Andy Mogel and it's about the world's most
pretentious 7-year-old named Allen Gregory.
And he has two dads and one of the dads is
an heiress.
And he loses the money and so Allen Gregory
has to go to public school for the first time
with normal kids and he finds this disgusting.
He doesn't wanna be around normal kids.
And I do the voice of Allen Gregory.
And let me tell you when I was growing up,
the Simpsons were my total, when my parents
asked me what I wanted to do when I was young,
they'd say what do you want to do when you
grow up?
And I said I wanna live in Springfield.
I was like 6 or 7 and with the Simpsons and
my parents said well that's, the Simpsons
is a show and there are animators who draw
Homer, there are people who, there's a guy
who does Homer's voice and there are people
who write what Homer says.
And I was like, I wanna be one of the people
who writes what Homer says.
So that was a bizarre dream, 'cause most kids
just answer like fireman, but I would be in
school and say I wanna write for an animated
prime-time sitcom and that was weird.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And you know then years later
you know Superbad had come out and I had done
some of these comedies that had been successful
and Fox had luckily asked me, they said do
you want to do the voice of an animated character
on one of our new shows and I said well if
I'm on one of your shows, you probably wouldn't
let me create my own show ever because you
already have me on your network, and they
were like, yeah, probably, but you don't have
a show.
And I was like, OK, hold on a second.
So I went Jarrad, one of the co-creators,
lived in my building and I went in there with
him and his partner Andy, his writing partner
and we stayed in a room for a few weeks and
after a few weeks we emerged with a pilot
for Allen Gregory and now October 30, after
the Simpsons' Treehouse of Horror episode,
we premier on Fox right after the Simpsons.
>>Interviewer: Awesome.
>>Jonah Hill: So that dream has come very
full circle to me.
I'm very overjoyed and overwhelmed by that,
you know.
>>Interviewer: Nice.
Now
[applause]
>>Jonah Hill: That's cool, yeah, very cool.
Thanks.
>>Interviewer: And you also have The Sitter
coming up later this year.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, The Sitter, if you liked,
like, Superbad and stuff like that, you're
gonna like The Sitter.
It's a, it's a really hard core R-rated babysitting
comedy.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And you know, you know those
movies, the idea behind that is you know those
movies where they're like you don't want this
guy watching your kids and it's like some
really cheesy Disney movie?
You really don't want this guy watching your
kids.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: The plot of that movie revolves
around me going to buy drugs for my girlfriend
while babysitting these kids as a favor to
my mom and one of the kids steals drugs from
Sam Rockwell and J.B.
Smoove, who are drug dealers, and chase us
around New York City.
And it's hysterical.
And David Gordon Green directed, who directed
Pineapple Express and it's a really crazy
fun one night in New York City kind of movie
with me and a bunch of kids.
And that comes out December 9.
And there's a cell phone, the poster, there's
a cell phone with a phone number like need
a sitter and there's a phone number on it
and they're like, we want you to leave a voice
mail so when people call this number, you,
you'll, they'll hear your voice.
And I go, well who has the phone?
And they're like, it's a hotline.
And I'm like, well why don't you just make
it a cell phone and give it to me and I'll
answer it.
'Cause you know Mike Jones, the rapper, he
did that, and so I was like just make it a
real number and I'll answer it.
And so they gave me a phone and I have the
phone, so if you call the number a few hours
a day I try and answer it as much as possible.
It's actually really fun so I can talk to
fans and stuff.
It's been really fun.
>>Interviewer: Do people believe it's you?
Do you get a lot of that?
>>Jonah Hill: Sometimes they don't initially
and then I'm like no, seriously me.
And then they're like, what are you doing?
And I'm like, brushing my teeth.
And they're like, you're boring.
I'm like, OK, sorry.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And then sometimes people don't
get that I, that I can't stay on the phone
like all day.
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: They're like, oh hang on let
me get this friend, hold on, he'll be here
in like 10 minutes, just hang on the phone.
I'm like, well I gotta, OK.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: I was gonna say from the trailer
of The Sitter it really, it really feels like
a character who is kind of a dick at the start
but presumably you have to root for by the
end of the movie and I was gonna say David
Gordon Green has worked on Eastbound and Down,
which is
>>Jonah Hill: Eastbound and Down's one of
the best shows ever.
>>Interviewer: I was kind of, was he a good
collaborator to just push you into that?
>>Jonah Hill: Dave is one of the greatest
people I've ever met in my entire life.
He's so inspirational.
He's so funny and weird and interesting and
you know him and Jody Hill and Danny McBride
have this collective, they went to school
together at North Carolina School for the
Arts or South Carolina School for the Arts,
I can't remember which one.
North Carolina School for the Arts and they,
they are just so unique and twisted and weird
and messed up and Eastbound and Down is such
a beautiful for me, just I've never, I have
nothing to do with it, I'm just a fan of it.
I think it's like some of the strongest work
being done right now.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: And just back to Moneyball
before we get to those internet questions.
You're obviously in the bay area this weekend,
you're not throwing out the opening pitch
this weekend or anything are you?
>>Jonah Hill: I am.
>>Interviewer: You are?
>>Jonah Hill: In Oakland, yeah.
>>Interviewer: Awesome, nice.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, I'm very excited.
[applause and cheering]
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, it's gonna be really cool.
Thanks for letting me do that.
Are you guys A's fans?
>>someone in audience: hooo
>>Jonah Hill: OK Got, got weird for a second.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Yikes.
OK That's my time.
>>Interviewer: I mean how do you spend like
opening weekend for a movie like this?
How are you gonna?
>>Jonah Hill: Well that's a, well I'm throwing
out the A's game this Sunday and then the
premier's Monday and then it doesn't come
out until the following Friday, so September
23, is when Moneyball opens, but I'm excited
to throw the first pitch out.
That's gonna be really exciting.
And how do I spend the opening weekend?
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Jonah Hill: Freaking out until I know how
if I'll be able to work again, financially
based on how the movie did.
Hollywood has this really bananas system that
is so different than what you guys at home
would know about and what I knew about when
I was in high school knowing movies and I
think it's so bizarre, like the first weekend
financial numbers that the movie makes is
so important to these people, you know.
It's like you almost immediately forget about
if you liked the movie or not.
So everyone gets real freaked out and worried
and I just kind of pace around until someone
calls me and tells me I get to do another
movie again or not.
But I'm so proud of this movie, it's like
I know it will, I know it will live on that
I don't need to stress, you know, and especially
because Brad Pitt's such a big movie star
that hopefully that helps in some way.
>>Interviewer: Nice.
I'm sure you'll do fine.
So because we're at YouTube one of our standard
questions is really, you know, if and when
you ever sing in front of a computer looking
at YouTube, what are you looking at?
>>Jonah Hill: Well you know YouTube, not to
blow smoke or whatever, but it's such a big
part of a writer's room.
So obviously on movie sets, every movie set
I've been on as an actor, you know during
'Cyrus', John C. Reilly, like one of the main
ways we bonded was trading YouTube videos
and you know in the writers' room for Allen
Gregory, the animated show, you know it's
a bunch of people writing comedy for a TV
show and you know trying to think of things
that are funny sometimes you need to be inspired
and you need to take breaks, constant, constant
breaks and procrastination and a lot of it
is just needing, needing a laugh and needing
something to entertain us in, in, in our writer's
internet, our writer's assistant, he controls
the internet in the room and it's, the home
page is YouTube because it's like, we'll say,
hey, alright, we're not writing anything good,
we haven't, we been stuck on this scene for
the past hour.
Pull up blah, blah, blah video and let's laugh
for a second.
So you know, it's a constant part of my day,
a constant part of the creative process, for
at least my creative process, because you
need breaks in the day that are short, 'cause
you don't have all the time in the world and
you need short breaks in the day that are
punchy and can make you entertained.
And that's really for me the service that
you guys provide that is really beneficial
to my creative process.
>>Interviewer: Cool.
So we have some questions that people asked
through the @Google Talks channel.
One of them is from a guy called Burgers Taste
Good.
>>Jonah Hill: Well, that's a great name.
Yes.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: He's not wrong there.
He likes the the game dude channel on YouTube
and he thinks you're great and wants to know
>>Jonah Hill: Thanks.
>>Interviewer: would you ever do a video with
the game dude?
I'm not sure if the game dude is also Burgers
Taste Good.
He may be asking on behalf of himself.
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, really?
I don't know what the game dude is, but burgers
do taste good and I wish him the best in his
hamburger consumption and life.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
So Brugger Chick from Seoul in Korea asked
what are your favorite movies, both of your
own and just in general?
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, OK.
My favorite movies, I mean I'm, I'm a big
cinephile.
Some of my favorite movies of all time.
My favorite movie is Goodfellas, that's my
favorite movie.
Rushmore, Election, Big Lebowski, Groundhog
Day, Midnight Cowboy, Tootsie, The Graduate,
I mean, all Paul Thomas Anderson's movies,
Adaptation.
I mean I could go on for a long time and I
won't bore you guys, but I guess some of my
favorite movies of my own is a very egomaniacal
question to answer and self-centered question
to answer, but I guess the ones I'm most proud
of, you know I'm really proud of all of them,
but I guess if I was like going to a space,
country, or like a different planet or something
and I had to say like here's like what I did,
I would probably give them Superbad and Cyrus
and Moneyball.
>>Interviewer: Nice.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
And my one scene in 40-Year-Old Virgin 'cause
I really liked that e-bay store guy.
I always wondered what happened to that guy.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
I was gonna ask you, though, there is a Superbad
question
>>Jonah Hill: He's wearing those boots, somewhere.
>>Interviewer: Where do you think the characters
from Superbad are now?
>>Jonah Hill: I, well we always talked about
that like if we-, if there was ever gonna
be another one, and I think the, well, Seth
and Evan wrote that and I guess it's Seth,
so maybe that guy is Seth now.
But we always talked about it like my character
would be living a depressing life in that
same town and Michael's character [chuckles]
would be like working here, successful and
happy and my guy would still be like at home
living with his parents.
So that's why we didn't make another one,
because we felt it would be more depressing.
[laughing]
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: So Ryan Sescomb from Boomer
in Texas asks, Jonah, you lost some weight
recently.
What was the hardest thing to give up and
any advice for anybody else?
>>Jonah Hill: Well, the hardest thing to give
up would be burgers, 'cause they taste good.
And any advice?
I don't know.
It's just like anything you're gonna do, like
you know when I wanted to become an actor
and start making movies, it was the same kind
of determination, the same kind of thing where
you're like, you make a decision and you're
like I know this is gonna be difficult, I
know it's not gonna be the easiest thing in
the world, but I'm determined to do it and
I really care, I'm really caring about this
decision.
So you just make it a priority and, and you
know when anyone's starting out in any business
or any sort of life endeavor or any sort of
relationship, you're, you're, you're starting
out with the intention to go all the way and
to me it was just a decision and I just made
a commitment to sticking to it.
>>Interviewer: Cool.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: So.
>>Jonah Hill: Except for all the hummus I
just ate backstage which was
>>Interviewer: Delicious and healthy.
>>Jonah Hill: Hummus, yeah, it was great.
Eat a lot of hummus at YouTube, that's my
advice, if you're ever, move to YouTube and
eat their hummus, that's how you'll stay healthy.
>>Interviewer: So
>>Jonah Hill: Right?
>>Interviewer: Absolutely.
>>Jonah Hill: Great.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Elaine Baseball from New York
said
>>Jonah Hill: No, seriously, can all of them
move here and eat your hummus all day?
>>Interviewer: We just opened the second floor,
so yeah, there's more space than there was.
>>Jonah Hill: OK, great, wonderful.
>>Interviewer: So Elaine Baseball from New
York says, Jonah.
>>Jonah Hill: Seriously, though how much hummus
do you have?
>>Interviewer: Um.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Do you have enough for everyone
on the internet or no?
>>Interviewer: Almost infinity, infinity hummus.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Is it true that there's a whole
'nother YouTube filled with hummus?
>>Interviewer: There is, it comes in a giant
tube every morning and they park it outside.
>>Jonah Hill: And it's yours?
>>Interviewer: They pipe it in.
There was a swimming pool downstairs, but
now it's just filled with delicious, delicious
hummus.
>>Jonah Hill: Hummus.
OK Do you put chlorine in the hummus so you
can swim in it still?
>>Interviewer: [Sigh]
>>Jonah Hill: So when people urinate in the
hummus it's not hazardous?
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: That's why it tasted the way
it did.
I had no idea.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: So Elaine Baseball from New
York wants to know, Jonah, I want
>>Jonah Hill: Do you like hummus?
Yes, I do like hummus.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Do you have a favorite flavor
of hummus?
Just generic?
>>Jonah Hill: Just YouTube flavor.
>>Interviewer: YouTube.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: With all those little dogs
on skateboards through it.
>>Jonah Hill: Is it true they grind up all
the videos that have stopped gotting getting
hits and they make the hummus out of it?
>>Interviewer: That's exactly how it's made.
>>Jonah Hill: It's made from forgotten YouTube
videos?
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
They're, they're not forgotten, they're just
recycled.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Matter can be created and destroyed.
>>Jonah Hill: Hummus is cool you guys.
I love hummus.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
From hummus to hip hop.
>>Jonah Hill: OK Yeah.
What's the question?
>>Interviewer: The question from Elaine Baseball
in New York, apparently at one time you were
talking about being a hip hop producer, was
there some, I don't know if that's true.
You know what happened with that?
And maybe is that a safe question for myself.
You have Method Man in this set or so maybe
there was some
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
Well when I was in high school I had an MPC
and I would make hip hop beats for fun, but,
and I thought that might have been some sort
of job opportunity, but then I realized I,
that seemed a lot harder as a 16-year-old
white dude without any like hip hop experience
at all.
And I just, you know honestly, I, I grew up
as worshiping hip hop.
I love it.
I love all kinds of music, I'm an audiophile
too, and I just love all different kinds of
music, but I'm a huge hip hop fan and that
was something that I was really interested
in, but then movies kind of pushed that out
of the way at a certain point.
>>Interviewer: And did you have any interactions
with Method Man on the pieces?
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, yeah, yeah, tons, he's great.
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
>>Jonah Hill: He told such cool stories.
I mean, for like I mean if my 16-year-old
self or 10-year-old self knew what I was doing
now and who I would be making movies with
and having experiences with, it would just
be too overwhelming or mind blowing for little
Jonah to understand, you know?
I would sit in my room and listen to Wu Tang
records every night when I got home from school
and, and watch movies and you know to be around
these people it's really inspiring and I just
try and learn as much as I can from them.
You know he had so many cool stories about
when they were starting out and what that
was like and for me that's like heaven to
hear about all that stuff.
>>Interviewer: And kind of connected to that,
Eso, I can't even pronounce it, E-S-O-E-Z-T-V
said like you developed a stand-up act when
you were working on Funny People, which I
guess is a similar kind of an on-stage microphone
kind of thing.
Is that something you're gonna go back to,
or was that
>>Jonah Hill: Never, never,
>>Interviewer: Never, no?
>>Jonah Hill: never, never, no.
I'm an actor [laughing] and stand-up is a
whole different art form and I think it's
arrogant, it would be arrogant of me to assume
like I can just go do stand-up, you know,
because I've been in some funny movies, or
whatever, you know.
Like guys like Chris Rock and Louis C.K.,
they're, they're brilliant at what they do
and it's just a different art form, you know.
And I'm was an actor playing a stand-up in
Funny People and I had to develop a stand-up
act and it was to this day probably the hardest
thing I'd ever had to do to prepare for a
movie because I went out for six months and
you know it takes people, honestly it takes
years to get great at being a stand-up comedian
and for me I love bouncing off of people,
whether it's in a dramatic scene or a comedic
scene, and in stand-up you're alone on stage
with a microphone saying, please laugh at
me.
And it's terrifying, you know?
[chuckles] It's really terrifying.
So I, it was such a courage, it gave me a
lot of courage as a performer, like practicing
for that, but I, I'll leave that to the guys
and women that are, that are brilliant at
it.
>>Interviewer: Cool.
We have a couple more internet questions but
we also have a couple of mics here on either
side, so if anybody has a question maybe you
could start making your way to the mic.
I Love Mostly Anything Two says have you ever
been stung by a bee?
>>Jonah Hill: What was the first part of the
question?
>>Interviewer: I, no the person who asked
the question is I Love Mostly Anything Two,
'cause mostly anything one was taken obviously.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Have you ever been stung by
a bee?
>>Jonah Hill: I have been stung by a bee.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: Yep.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
Mongo Man One from Michigan wants to know
if
>>Jonah Hill: I know him.
>>Interviewer: You do?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: He apparently couldn't ask
you this in person and decided to ask you
this via the internet.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Have you ever considered being
a song and dance man?
Could you see yourself in a musical opposite
Hugh Jackman?
>>Jonah Hill: I don't know about opposite
Hugh Jackman, but I'd love to be in a musical.
I love to, you know John C. Reilly in Chicago
or something like that or maybe like Little
Shop of Horrors, you know something, something
like that.
They've actually talked to me about some musical
stuff and I would never like be one of those
actors who releases an album or anything stupid
like that, but I would, I would love to be
in like a musical movie or maybe a play sometime,
it would be really fun.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
Your final internet question, also from Mongo
Man One, he left several, do you have an opinion
on the designated batter rule?
>>Jonah Hill: I'm OK with it.
>>Interviewer: You're OK with it?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
>>Jonah Hill: I don't lose sleep over it.
>>Interviewer: You don't lose sleep, fair
enough.
Do you want to start taking some questions?
>>Jonah Hill: Sure.
>>female #1: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I, we saw Moneyball the other night and thought
it was great.
>>Jonah Hill: Thanks.
>>female #1: I too am a fan of the hummus,
so I'm gonna bring it back, actually had it
for snack time today.
>>Jonah Hill: I love hummus-based questions.
[laughter]
>>female #1: So, since there's plain and spicy,
I'm wondering which one you had.
>>Jonah Hill: I had plain.
>>female audience member #1: OK
>>Jonah Hill: You know my feelings on it,
but I imagine that there's also a place in
my heart for spicy hummus.
>>female #1: And did you have the carrots
or chips or what was your dipper?
>>Jonah Hill: Well, what I did was, now I'm
gonna throw a real curve ball at you right
now.
I didn't dip anything into the hummus.
[laughter]
>>female audience member #1: OK
>>Jonah Hill: And, I didn't eat the hummus
plain.
What I did was, was there was a salad there
that had like garbanzo beans and tomatoes
and onions and I put the hummus on top of
it and smushed it all around and ate that
and it was so cool.
[laughter]
>>female #1: Alright, thank you.
>>Jonah Hill: Isn't that why you guys are
watching this, right now?
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: So that's my recommendation
is mix your hummus with stuff, mix it up,
get crazy out there, internet, you know.
Don't, don't just dip stuff in your hummus,
make your hummus what you want it to be.
Swim in it.
>>Interviewer: Nice.
Do you want to kind of go back and forth,
take both sides?
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, sure, yeah.
>>male #1: How's it going?
>>Jonah Hill: Hey.
>>male #1: I'd like to start off by saying
you should mix the spicy and regular hummus.
>>Jonah Hill: OK
>>male #1: That's the way to go.
>>Jonah Hill: Mild.
Make your own mild hummus.
[laughter]
>>male #1: Exactly.
>>Jonah Hill: Right.
>>male #1: So I heard a rumor that there was
a lot of prank pulling on the set of Moneyball?
>>Jonah Hill: Yes.
>>male #1: And I heard a lot of that was on
Brad Pitt's side.
I was wondering if you got him back at all?
>>Jonah Hill: They, OK, so there were a lot
of pranks on the Moneyball set.
Ninety-four percent of them were Brad directed
at me.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: He got me really good.
I had this golf cart that I was really excited
about because I felt that it was a symbol
that I had finally become successful that
they gave me my own golf cart.
So just him and I had our own golf carts to
drive around the set and stuff, so we would
race and smash into each other and it was
really fun.
And he knew how much I cared about this golf
cart, and so we would go do like a really
serious scene and then I'd walk out and like
the golf cart would have no wheels on it,
it would be on cinder blocks.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And he would just walk outside
and smile and he was in the scene with me,
which means he has little prank elves that
like
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: do this stuff while you're working.
And then I'd walk out another time and it'd
be completely upside down.
And then I'd walk out another time and there'd
be male genitalia, fake male genitalia hanging
from the back of it.
And then one time I was driving my actual
car home and my friend was driving behind
me and called me and said, hey, I'm driving
behind you, there's pink male genitalia hanging
from the back of your car.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And then I got an e-mail from
him, saying, how was the drive home?
And then eventually he became obsessed with
me being obsessed with the band Wham, which
he just, made it, made it clear that he thought
I liked the band Wham.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: And so I'd walk into my character's
office and there'd be a framed Wham poster
in there instead of a framed Oakland poster
and then my golf cart got wrapped in all pink,
you know like car wraps?
And then there was the time when there was
a Photoshop picture of me and him as the two
members of Wham on the front and it said,
Jonah Hill #1 Wham Fan and then on the side
it said Wham Mobile.
And then the final prank was every time I
turned on the engine, he had it rigged so
it blasted Wake Me Up Before You Go Go.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: At full volume on a loop anytime
I had an engine on.
So if I had a meeting with an executive at
Sony or something, I would have to drive over
there in this, this golf cart.
[laughter]
>>male #1: But you never got him back?
>>Jonah Hill: I did but I'm gonna be on Letterman
on Tuesday and I'm waiting to show my pranks
back on him there, no offense.
>>male #1: I respect that.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Moving on, question over here.
>>Jonah Hill: Yes.
>>male #2: Hey, so big fan.
One of the things that I love about your movies
is that you seem to have this like really
great relationship with a lot of the other
comedians, you know, and I'm just wondering
is that just great acting or you know is there
something [inaudible]
>>Jonah Hill: Yes, I hated all, all of them.
They're all terrible people.
>>male audience member #2: So how is it working
with like you know it seems like a tight-knit
group of [inaudible]
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, you know like Paul Rudd
and Michael Cera and Seth Rogen and Jason
Segel and Danny McBride and all these guys,
and Franko, and all, all these people you
know a lot of us came up together, you know,
started together and it was a lot of us became
successful at the same time and with each
other.
So what I liked about that a lot and we're
all still friends, but it's been interesting
because now we've all, we're all doing our
own movies kind of thing, so it's not as much
as like a gang, and not because we don't still
love each other and wanna make movies together
all the time, which we do, but everyone's
kind of following their dream that they had
independently before.
And now it's kind of hard since we all became
actually employable, before we were unemployable,
so it's like, hey you guys wanna all be in
a movie together?
We're like, hell yeah.
But now we're all employable, so we'll take
a movie and then someone else will take a
movie and the schedules, the schedules are
really hard to align and have all the planets
align all at once.
But they're, all those guys, are the greatest
group of guys ever.
I mean they're all so funny.
And if we're ever somewhere and one of us
sees the other one, it does feel like we gravitate
towards one another, and hang out with each
other at that party or whatever it would be.
And I don't know, I really look at that time
as my college experience, you know, because
my early 20s were spent with this really fun
group of guys making each other laugh.
Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Any more takers?
>>female #2: [inaudible]
>>Interviewer: Excellent.
>>Jonah Hill: I'm not gonna twist your arm,
you know.
>>female #2: Alright, fine, OK.
>>Jonah Hill: Yes the hummus was great.
>>female #2: I'm also a huge Wham fan.
>>Jonah Hill: OK, yeah.
>>female #2: What's your favorite song?
That's not my question, but I'm just curious.
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, I'm not actually a Wham
fan.
>>female #2: Oh, that's the whole point then.
Oh I am, a card-carrying
>>Jonah Hill: That was the joke was that he
decided I was a Wham fan.
I have nothing, I don't even understand, I
think Wham is probably awesome.
I only know that one song.
I know like the big T-shirt with the sayings
on it.
>>female #2: You know there's a song where
they rap, it's really good.
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, really?
>>female #2: Yeah, you should check it out.
>>Jonah Hill: Alright, well I gotta get on
that.
>>female #2: Well I was, I saw the movie Get
Him to the Greek which I'm a big fan of because
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, thanks.
>>female #2: because I used to be an assistant
to a minor English musical celebrity.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>female #2: And so it reminded me a lot of
myself, your character.
Do you have any tips for, I'm an assistant
here, but it's not the same, it's not as bad.
Do you have tips for
>>Jonah Hill: They don't make you shove heroin
up your bum?
[laughter]
>>female #2: No comment.
>>female #2: I plead the fifth.
Would you have any tips for anything you learned
on set when you were filming that for someone
who has to take care of a celebrity?
>>Jonah Hill: Are you calling your boss a
crazy person?
>>female #2: No, not my boss here, but you
know maybe in the past.
>>Jonah Hill: Sure.
>>female #2: Any tips for dealing with a minor
celebrity?
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah, I don't know, somewhere
else man.
>>female #2: Yeah.
Just winky face, winky face.
>>Jonah Hill: It was at WhoWhube, another
company you worked at right before this?
I don't know.
I guess you'd have to ask these guys who work
with me.
>>female #2: How was it working with Seth?
I mean Seth, oh Jonah, sorry, oh I guess I
just got in my head earlier.
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
No, it's OK.
I don't know, I think working with me's probably
pretty easy.
I think Russell Brand's character was probably
a really big exaggeration of, of what that
was like.
I've never worked for a rock star, so I don't,
I don't really know, but I imagine that's
a really arduous task.
>>female #2: Alright.
Thank you.
>>Jonah Hill: Thank you.
>>Interviewer: OK, Jonah.
>>Jonah Hill: Oh, wait, this girl was about
to stand up.
>>Interviewer: Sorry, my apologies.
>>female #3: Do you have a girlfriend and
if so does she like hummus as much as you?
>>Jonah Hill: I am dating hummus currently.
It's a giant gelatinous hummus person that
I've carved out of hummus and we're engaged,
so.
No, you know, I try not to talk about like
my family or friends or stuff like that because,
because you know I signed up to be doing this
and it's crazy if you are pulled into something
that you didn't sign up for, you know what
I mean?
But I am dating someone, yes, and she's made
of hummus
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: and she's great.
>>Interviewer: She's delicious, I'm sure.
>>Jonah Hill: She's frozen hummus.
I mean what's not to love?
It's hummus but it's freezing cold.
Why did this become the centerpiece of this
interview?
Why do I regret doing this? [laughing]
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: I think there's more back there.
>>Jonah Hill: OK, cool, I'm looking forward
to it.
>>Interviewer: As we've established there's
infinite hummus.
So to wrap up, Jonah, do you have any final
thoughts about Moneyball that you want to
share?
>>Jonah Hill: I just think it's a really wonderful
moving movie and it's, it's a rare treat for
me to get to be a part of a movie like this
and I'm just really, really proud of it and
thank you guys for watching or coming to this
and if you want to see a good movie September
23, go see Moneyball, it won't let you down.
>>Interviewer: Excellent, well
>>Jonah Hill: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: I just ask everybody then to
thank me in or join me in thanking you for
being here Jonah.
[laughter]
>>Jonah Hill: OK cool.
>>Interviewer: Yeah, could you also thank
me for that?
No.
>>Jonah Hill: Awesome.
Oh, thank what?
[applause]
>>Interviewer: Thank, thank you for being
with us.
>>Jonah Hill: Thanks, appreciate it.
>>Interviewer: OK.
>>Jonah Hill: Alright, thanks.
>>Interviewer: Cheers.